question for you for fatherlessness
stats I saw this the other day and I
speak on this a lot and I think a part
of
what's going on today with the momentum
of Tate and with the momentum of you
know what you've been speaking about
with Prager University on the role
family nucleus you're seeing this being
talked about everywhere I see the stat
and I want to know how we got here and
how we need to fix this okay so here are
the stats the US has the highest rate of
children living in single parent
households of Any Nation about 80
percent of single-parent homes are led
by single mothers at a rate of 20 23
percent of children living with one
parent and no other adult the United
States is three times the world average
of seven percent so 23 percent is U.S
seven percent is World average China's
three percent India's four percent okay
where a mom isn't there or that isn't
there even for children with a father
present in the home the average school
age boy only spends about 30 minutes per
week
in one-on-one conversations with his
father for comparison the same boy on
average will spend about 44 hours per
week watching television playing video
games and surfing the internet ninety
percent of all homelessness and runaway
children 63 percent of teen suicide 85
percent of children and teens with
behavioral disorders come from
fatherless homes fatherlessness likewise
has a direct link to teen pregnancy and
sexual activity roughly 70 percent of
teenage pregnancies come from women
raised in fatherless homes and these
times these same women have
significantly higher abortion rates than
women raised by both a father and a
mother on the whole fatherless kids are
20 times more likely to be incarcerated
and 11 times more likely to exhibit
violent Behavior than children of two
parent households if a man and a wife
this one's one of the most interesting
stats if a man and a wife raise a child
they're less likely to end up in jail
but
they have the same chance as children
raised by just their fathers let me read
that one more time if a man and a wife
raise a child they're less likely to end
up in jail but they have the same
chances as children raised by just only
their fathers girls with no fathers have
low self-esteem and obviously this ties
to Crime mental issues economy suicide
rates all these other things one how did
we get here okay was this intentional to
want to break the family nucleus word
this is not a Leader's bulletin we want
to be winning in like this is not
something to be bragging about we're
we're a very competitive Nation we want
to be the best at Innovation we want to
be the best in this and that this is not
a place to brag about how do we get here
and Dennis what's the solution
one of the ways we got here was the
feminist movement
one of its mottos was a woman without a
man is like a fish without a bicycle
very famous phrase from early feminism
in the 60s 70s
men are essentially regarded as useless
we need we need their sperm and other
than that we really don't need men kids
don't need men I I cite in something I
wrote a New York Times survey of experts
quote unquote which usually means
foolish people who know one thing
and uh the the the whole heading was our
our fathers necessary it was actually a
a big column uh in the New York Times
and and repeatedly
that fathers are not necessary again the
secular intellectual is is generally a
stupid person
fathers are essential
everything you read proves it and yet we
we live
in a world that denies the obvious
that's a good phrase for the Modern Age
the the denial of the obvious
girls without fathers in their lives are
far more promiscuous and you may say so
what
and the answer to the show what is well
there is a what the what is they get
more depressed
they they get angrier they're less
they're less happy
and uh I am
I've written a book on happiness because
I consider happiness to be an extremely
important part of life the happy make
the world better the unhappy make it
worse
happiness is a moral issue not just an
emotional issue
how did we get here we got here once
again thanks to secularism
religious homes are far more likely to
have a father in them
people are not willing to acknowledge
that the roots of Western Civilization
which are called judeo-christian when
you abolish the roots of a civilization
the trees fall down I mean I don't know
why that shouldn't be obvious what are
we going to supplant it with
and we have supplanted it with with
again foolish ideas
men are not necessary women don't need
them and children don't need them
and so the men got the message
and now what do we have seven million
able-bodied men young able-bodied men
who have taken themselves out of the
workplace
this is a tragedy for society it is a
tragedy for
uh for men and it's a tragedy for women
looking for a good man to marry
it's also part of the uh another secular
idiocy of the left and that is that you
don't need to marry
this is uh this is an old-fashioned idea
that people should marry
three generations of women starting with
with the Baby Boomers of which I am a
member were taught uh yeah you want to
get married get married but young woman
the thing that will bring you the
greatest joy and happiness and
fulfillment is career which is one of
the greatest lies uh in in the world of
Lies
it's it's it's really as much a lie as
men give birth
but
when you hear something enough you start
to believe it oh I don't I don't really
need marriage I'll be great with a
career
I've written over a thousand columns
they're all on the internet 20 years
about 50 a year
and only one of them I didn't write
all I did was transcribe a call to my
radio show
and I have a male female hour every week
and I discuss this issue tell me if you
pursued career and not marriage has it
worked out for you
50-year-old woman who was a CEO makes a
good living
she has three degrees from universities
and essentially
almost in tears
spoke eloquently about how
being a CEO doesn't quite compensate for
going home to an empty home
when she sees friends with a husband and
children and everybody knows marriages
have issues and children are issues
but the purpose of life is not to avoid
issues it's to embrace the fullness of
life
and and I'll just say Point Blank
because nobody nobody tells people
things they don't want to hear everybody
wants to be loved I have no such aim
and uh you don't grow up if you don't
get married this is a message to men
this is a message to women
you can be very successful uh you don't
grow up okay you can be a wonderful
human being good volunteer services you
can you know you can adopt uh stray
puppies and and do all sorts of things
you every married person including
people who married and had a lousy
marriage and divorced
will acknowledge they grew up when they
got married and then you grow up
exponentially when you have children and
you're married but people don't want to
grow up the left is Peter Pan the left
is the embracing of immaturity
and you have the most professors are
immature people
and they they help develop immature
young people
it is a catastrophe they don't hear from
people like me obviously they do I mean
I I let me let me make this they don't
hear from people like me meaning that
we're not their professors we try to go
around it with prageru with lectures
with books and and not just me thank God
there are other wonderful people giving
good messages uh but uh we're censored I
mean to and and Ben Shapiro went to
Berkeley and they had six hundred
thousand dollars in security there's no
security for the most radical leftist
speaker they don't need one bodyguard
why do conservatives need six hundred
thousand dollars of security
do people not put two and two together
the damage the left does all it does is
destroy the American Medical Association
has announced that
the sex of a child should not be on a
birth certificate because we don't know
it until they choose it this is the
American Medical Association can you
pull this up yes pull it up
the American yes the American see this
is the this is the thing people don't
know the damage the left does to
everything it touches art music
education children male female relations
and Medicine it has corrupted the
medical field the American Society of
American Academy of Pediatrics or
pediatricians whatever the full name is
they've come out for affirmative care to
give miners uh uh hormone blockers
I mean that is evil you want yes that's
a new evil you asked for a new evil what
we're doing to kids now in the name of
trans uh of of of of transgender is pure
evil
you know Dennis you talked about
happiness and the book you're
referencing for people that are
listening he was referencing his book
happiness is a serious problem which if
you haven't read it read it he's not on
a book tour this was written many many
years ago but the truths that are in
there about finding purpose and the
things that you do and that the pursuit
of happiness is not the pursuit of joy
you know Joy is deeper in your heart
happiness is hey my team won today it
was a pretty good day and if all you're
searching for is those
those moments of Happiness that's that's
not Joy it's the deeper Joy about
service and what you do and purpose in
life and thank you for writing that book
Thank You Chuck Colson the late Chuck
Coulson wrote how now shall we live
Wonderful book you're probably familiar
with
and he was talking about the steps out
what do you think are some of the steps
out because you've very eloquently lives
out of what what you're what you're
talking about here what initial steps
out you know as a society as people or
as a country you you talk about the left
very eloquently what are our initials
I'll I'll give you uh a terrific first
step
to know that you have to fight your
nature you can't develop as a human
being you can't even be a happy human
being if you don't fight your nature
that's the number one issue in life
unpack then okay first of all
uh human nature is not basically good
only the naive who live who have lived a
spoiled life believe the nonsense that
human nature is basically good I don't
say human nature is basically evil I'm
saying it's not basically good you uh
number two your own nature there are two
Natures we have we all have human nature
and we all have our own Natures you have
to battle both my father told me all of
my childhood I'm lazy
I didn't like hearing it thank God he
said it to me my father my father
criticized me way more than he praised
me and I'm a better man for that fact
much better there's no comparison
and uh because
I that's not the role the role of a
parent
in the the world of the of the stupid in
which we live is to give kids
self-esteem so you give them trophies
for playing not trophies for winning
trophies for playing that's damaging to
children
you don't think you have to achieve in
in order to get a reward from society
well you do kid you have to achieve if
you didn't win you don't get a trophy
end of issue
so the first thing people call my show
and they go Dennis you're a father
figure to me I'm having a kid give me a
piece of advice and I always have the
same
give them teach them self-control not
self-esteem you get self-esteem from
self-control
self-control is the route to self-esteem
it is the route to happiness it is the
root to a productive it is the the root
the only route to a good life your words
carry a lot of weights I want to I want
to unpack what you just said right there
will your father give you by the way the
same thing you're you're lazy you're
lazy you're lazy that's the one thing my
dad kept telling me when I was a kid so
it's very common to what my dad told me
as a kid I read this book called the
Genius in all of us 15 years ago 14
years ago and maybe 10 years ago in the
statistic it showed in there it said
there in the three different classes of
parents lower class middle class upper
class okay so lower middle upper lower
class from from the day the kid is born
to 18 they are uh uh they get Negative
affirmations means nose and rejections
600 times 600 000 times more than
positive lower class middle was a
hundred thousand more negative
affirmative Nation okay then positive
and the upper class parents to their
kids was a hundred thousand more than
criticism makes sense that's what this
book is talking about the genius and
I'll achieved the more you were
criticized is that what you're no the
parents of the parents of the upper
class parents the way they spoke to
their kids is what she did was wrong but
I believe you can improve this dot dot
versus the lower class parents would say
you're an idiot you're a [ __ ] why'd you
do that so today my father was right I
was lazy calling a kid an idiot or a
[ __ ] is not helpful that's what I mean
you can't overcome being an idiot or a
[ __ ] I mean that that's the parent is
an idiot and a moral I agree it says
that yes so I'm not advocating that I
know you're not I'm I'm advocating the
opposite though of what we're doing oh
you're terrific oh my God you made a
bowel movement I I gotta get you a prize
that is the most beautiful poop I have
ever seen in my life or it's America's
favorite word it was an awesome poop oh
my God I mean so it never ends the
constant praise it doesn't mean anything
or or you become a narcissist you expect
that praise
there's got to be a balance parents
should be real you did a good job good
I I commend you a good job you did a bad
job you did a bad job
my wife who I I think she was a single
mom and she sort of uh uh is it is an
outlier because she raised a kid two
wonderful boys
and I'm saying because she's my wife
it's just a fact you meant she's a
lawyer well she she she
is a lawyer but she doesn't practice for
sure yes anyway she so she told her kids
as follows
and I hope I get it right and she's
she's listening right now
she's a little worried but basically
if you if you do something wrong if
you're guilty and the police pick you up
don't waste your one phone call on me
hmm
that that was a very direct statement to
kids uh you use drugs that night you
don't sleep in my house
I that that's that's good stuff I asked
on my radio show my radio show has been
my human laboratory because I not only
talked two millions I talk with tens of
thousands with that's an amazing thing
to say
and I've learned an immense amount so I
often just ask questions if you didn't
use drugs in high school
why didn't you
and I had no idea what the answers would
be virtually everything isn't it what a
great question so right so here was the
answer
overwhelmingly they all said the same
thing men and women my mother would kill
me
specifically the mother the yes isn't
that interesting mother would kill yes
my mother would kill not the father well
the the Assumption in a two-parent home
is
if you get by your mother your father
will torture you you know I don't know
what's worse than killing you but uh you
know she's the first line of defense you
you know once I kill you he'll dismember
you I don't know but but yes she's the
first line of defense yeah gotcha well
yesterday I was playing football with my
nephew right I don't have kids I'm
working on it
um uh but I I take an active role in my
nephew's life and I he's the only child
and I I've seen that he's sort of been
coddled a little bit and it's kind of my
job as the uncle to be like toughen up
kid and every time I said every time you
catch the ball we have to catch it throw
it back and forth 10 times if you you
know then we move on to the next lesson
and every time he dropped there was an
excuse oh it's slippery outside all the
sun's in my eye oh it's muddy whatever
it is I'm like listen if the ball hits
your hand you gotta catch a kid that's
the bottom line here right I played
football that's my thing if it hits your
hand you got to catch it my question to
you is this uh I said once you we're
done with this you'll get a reward for
actually doing well if you don't do good
today you get nothing so he's he's
negotiating well can I get this can I
get that you talked about the trophy
culture and everybody gets something if
for the for the young parents out there
who are raising kids how should what
give me some case examples like if they
screw up
how should you address it and if they do
well how should you address it
so it depends what the screw-up means uh
if the screw-up is a moral screw-up
which is the only ones I am really
concerned with uh then they need to be
punished uh I I here's another message
in addition to the you you have to
control you have to fight your nature
the most important message of all but I
I had uh I had another message to my
kids I which is almost unheard of for a
Jewish upper middle class parent it's
almost unheard of but I said to my kids
repeatedly I don't care about your
grades
which is almost unheard of I mean I know
among my peers they they found it almost
unbelievable that I did this all I care
about is your character
okay so I don't I don't care about your
grades all I care about is your
character
and uh I think I have two good kids on
one went through a very difficult time
uh he he one of my kids is biological
one one of my kids is adopted for a day
from the day of birth he was born
through a meth addict mother I did not
know that at the time and that that
played havoc in his early life as it
turns out he's terrific today he's
married he wants to make a family he's
he's he I I thank God for him my older
son was was never a a difficult issue uh
and uh but uh that was my message to
them character is is all that matters to
me so if you like this clip and you want
to watch another one click right here
and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign